1 divided by x plus y is correct. Fantastic work if you figured that one out.
You might not be sure what to cancel here. So let's look at one fraction, and
our factors multiplied together. First I'm going to expand this power of two.
The quantity x plus y squared is really x plus y times x plus y. Now we just
multiply our numerators across and our denominators across. I need to make sure
to put parentheses around this x plus y, since we would really be distributing
this 2x to each of the terms. We could see that here. But I don't actually want
to distribute or multiply the 2x to each term, since you want to be able to
cancel factors here and here. These factors reduce to 1, and we're left with a 1
in the numerator and an x plus y in the denominator. You want to make sure that
you don't think the numerator is zero. These factors really reduce to 1, so we
have 1 times 1, which is 1. Some fractions will end up with a 1 in numerator,
and others might have a 1 in the denominator. You'll want to watch out for that.